hi Secretary Philip Hammond there now
there are reports this morning though of
deepening divisions within the
Conservative Party about Europe The
Sunday Times has a warning that David
Cameron could face a leadership
challenge if the so-called
blue-on-blue attacks do not stop it's
after what's been seen as a thinly
veiled attack on the Mayor of London
Boris Johnson in the House of Commons
last week well I'm joined now by the
business minister and a super she's in
Nottingham and a very good morning to
you Anna soory are you saying oh dear
it's all turning a bit nasty now now I'm
saying oh dear this is so boring for
ordinary viewers who are not interested
in this media bubble mainly centred in
Westminster out here in the real world
people want to know the issues they want
to know why we are going to be safer
stronger and better off in Europe and
equally they want to know what it looks
like if they were to vote and of course
it's about the individual votes that
will be cast on June the 24th what it
will look like if we were to leave the
EU that's what people want to know about
not this media bubble it's dreadful
Dermott ah the media bubble argument
don't you think they want to know though
who's going to be Justice Secretary that
Michael Gove might be sacked for
campaigning on the other side well they
do I don't know because we had a general
election under a year ago I'm nothing
right let's get a few things straight
right the media got the result of the
general election spectacularly wrong the
reason they got it wrong because they
sat in comfortable studios and they
listened to media commentators and that
was but forgive me but that's lazy
journalism get out into the real world
listen to what real people are saying
that's where I was on Friday for example
I was out in my fright ruin see with a
group of Lib Dems greens labour all of
us on the doorstep talking to real
people about why we believe we should
stay in the EU they weren't remotely
interested in the mashaa nations as
perceived by the media at the
Conservative Party
okay so just focus this we just have to
clear this up I'm sorry yeah and it's
really important Minister I just want to
clear this up you're saying about saying
it's a media invention it's a media
invention that the media are making it
are that there are considerations that
ministers who campaign on the leaves
it may well be reshuffled after the
referendum now that is something people
do want to know what the makeup of the
government don't I don't care do they
who's in charge nope they absolutely
want to know what the arguments are for
staying in and what the arguments are
for staying out that's what people want
to know and it's easy the journalists to
sit and have all these machination talk
about all these personalities out here
in the real world that is what turns
people off politics they don't like it
personality led politics they want to
know the argument so please ask me the
question challenge me have me up with a
good strong debate with somebody who
doesn't believe in it in all the rest of
it don't let's just get boring about
personalities that's not what it's about
what you mentioned I mean you mentioned
and I've mentioned as well the general
election well the core plank of the
general election we have to revisit that
having you just having said the people
don't care who's in charge what was one
of the main planks of the conservative
campaign was that our leader David
Cameron is better than the then Labour
leader that was all about personality
wasn't it no it wasn't actually it was
because about the party it was about the
policies the politics of those people
yes there are issues and times when of
course people will look at whether
somebody has the qualities of a prime
minister in terms for example of
leadership and obviously that will
debate will come in 2020 but here now in
the real world people want to know why I
believe so passionately that we are
better off stronger and safer remaining
in the United in remaining in the EU and
that's the debate I want to have that's
what people tell me and I think that
that is the way we should now look at
all of this always people are just going
to be turned off in their droves they
don't know my shoes that's because of
the moment politics is over let's go
over the debate let me put one of the
issues right absolutely brilliant God
let me put let me put them to you
because so doesn't this turn people off
the fact that your side is over egging
the doom mongering the so-called project
fear today we've been told we're hearing
from the Europe Minister that we face
decades in economic limbo if we leave
the European Union the Chancellor's been
talking with the g20 and the Chinese
come up with the whole
world economy is threatened by the UK
leaving the EU you're overdoing that
aren't either scare mongering well
actually I mean I thought no I don't
think it is I think there is a really
valid debate to have be had about what
does it look like if people were to vote
in this referendum to leave the EU and
when I looked into this in article 50
and what that then means the procedure
that is then triggered off it would take
at least two years to get out of the EU
and of course in that two years we would
see chaos look last week when some
people decided that they were going to
be in favor of us leaving the EU we saw
that the value of the pound plummeted we
also know that Moody's very important
agency has said that our credit rating
would go down if we were to leave the EU
so that's not the views of just
politicians these are learning reading
agencies got anything news of the crash
no way organizations that know what
they're talking about sorry there are
economists there are economists who say
the term the pound falling is a good
thing we can export more you know
where's this economic limbo coming from
mmm but I think that you look at the
what would actually happen if we were to
leave the EU there would be at least two
years where we have to disentangle
ourselves and what business says to me
is that uncertainty is the thing that
they dread the most they need certainty
to do business and unfortunately two
years of uncertainty would really harm
British business but in any event I make
a strong positive case for us remaining
in the EU it has huge benefits for
people not just my generation but of
course my children and my grandchildren
it has delivered growth and prosperity
and jobs 500 million people over the
channel that we trade with 40 percent up
to 50 percent of our exports going into
that single market that's where our
future lies as well of course as all the
other trade agreements that we reach
with other countries where we want to do
business but primarily staying in the EU
has provided us with growth and
prosperity and will continue to do soon
especially as its reforming itself I
mean I actually believe that Cameron has
caught this wind of change that's
beginning to blow across the EU right
and I think we're going to drive that
yeah I just want to squeeze in the last
a last question that even you can't
accuse the media of making up and this
from the cabinet secretary Sir Jeremy
Heywood banning ministers banning
ministers from access to a civil
servants and their research if they want
to make their arguments to leave that
that's not hardly fair is it actually
I'm really sorry to to upset you about
this but actually I genuinely don't know
anything about that because it's
something that's not come my way at all
and I'm sure that Sir Jeremy who are the
after all is completely you're in
government and the leading member hang
on hang on a moment I haven't heard
about any cheeky it was heard about I've
heard about it I've read it no no ever
actually you see that just proves my
point
everybody in the real world genuinely
hasn't heard about it this is media
bubble but look if this is an important
issue and I'm not saying that it isn't
then of course so Jeremy will make sure
that the right thing is done that's what
I would say about it but it's just
something that's not come my way I
promise you so that's all I would have
to say because I trust the Jeremy
Hayward he's our leading civil servant
he's completely independent and he's
extremely good he'll do the right thing
okay well honestly we good to talk to
you cause no one cares so who's doing
the job so a business minister for the
time being who knows who you have to let
have a go later on that's what you said
thank you very much